Today, we'll talk about explanation-based learning.
In explanation-based learning, the agent doesn't learn about new concepts.
Instead, it learns about connections among existing concepts.
We'll use explanation-based learning to introduce the notion of transfer of
knowledge from an old situation to a new situation. This will help us
set up infrastructure needed for talking about analogical reasoning next time.
Today, we'll start by talking about a concept space where we will map out all
the concept and relationships between them. Then we introduce the notion of
abstraction that helps us do transfer. Finally, we'll use transfer to
build complex explanations that will lead to explanation-based learning.